right
um
all right welcome uh everyone to the
ddps seminar today uh before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q a session at the
end second today is ddps seminar is open
to external audiences so no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel uh
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
yeah it is an honor to host dark harkman
who is an industrial mathematicians at
Siemens Tech and the Siemens technical
fellow entrepreneur and thought leader
in the field of solution and digital
twins
among many distinctions he received the
prestigious 101 cement top innovator
award for his lifetime achievements and
the Siemens inventor of the Year 2021
multiple of his Innovations have led to
novel products and services have been
showcased at top level Innovation events
as well as have been covered by external
media in his career Dirk took several
leading roles in research Innovation and
Development Across Siemens including the
lead of a multi-million Siemens lnd
program and the technical leadership for
the simulation and digital twins filled
that Siemens technology with more than
120 scientists across the globe
is a passionate Mentor teacher and
supervisor for the next generation of
innovators and experts exploring novel
digital twin solutions for all
Industries
today he will talk about machine
learning and physics-based simulations
of industrial digital twins it is very
interesting topics so please enjoy his
wonderful talk now without further ado
let me pass the button to Dirk by asking
one random question as as we usually do
today's random question is what is your
favorite things to do other than
research
well you know typically I always say
this is my hobby and that's my favorite
thing to do
so I guess my next favorite thing is is
really my family and my four kits
um you have a fortnight yes I do so
that's kind kind of you know the two
things uh mathematics uh the research
around in my family well we have things
come on I have a full case too okay
great all right it's all yours dark okay
thanks a lot for for the very very nice
um in introduction
um
and and you mentioned I I enjoy very
much until so I try to do that right now
at Siemens you know working a lot
together with a younger generation
students whether it's Master students
PhD students
um so that's why really this this is a
summary of all my you know students
collaborators working with them on these
topics you see at the bottom mainly the
Technical University of Munich as well
as the University of mcderberg
um
the focus of my talk will be well as as
written machine learning and
physics-based simulations but I would
write really like to take here an
industrial point of view so take an
application point of view rather than
going very very deep uh into the
individual mathematical models my
business is really you know trying to
Spur a little bit of research getting
into a discussion exchange
um to to Really drive here here the
mathematics or computational science and
research because I think that that
really has
to play a very pivotal role when it
comes to the Future industry
applications also a small disclaimer
um it's written there machine learning
but for most of parts of the talks I'll
really use data driven and machine
learning synonymously so it will not
only be all neural network but also good
all classical polynomials
um Etc
good um the structure of the talk is a
little bit well why digital twins you
know um obviously as can see from the
slides I'm working at Siemens why why is
Siemens so excited about digital Twins
then
a very very short Deep dive on digital
twins don't want to spend too much on
that and then really go to the core
topic machine learning and physics-based
simulations
so why digital Twins and why digital
twins add at Siemens
um you know Siemens has changed it's
portfolio over the past years quite
quite a lot
and you know if you would ask now anyone
at Siemens what is really our mission
our vision that's all about combining
the real and and the digital world and
we do that you know for for customers in
all the different verticals uh areas
from here from food and beverage or to
to Pulp and Paper or life sciences
and really support them on on their
digital transformation and
sustainability journey and challenges
if you speak about you know digital and
the real world
um and connecting that then at the heart
of that that is really the digital twin
the comprehensive digital twin so the
digital representation of
of real world assets
um to be
in or to be used as a replica of the
real world sufficiently accurate are
tightly connected so that you can do you
know lots of what if scenarios
Etc and really support decision making
in the end
so that is is kind of of the usual story
I always tell speaking about Siemens um
but this time I have to add something so
um we really try now to push these These
Days um to the limits and actually
um you know it's it's not only about
connecting the real and the digital
world but the key ingredient here is
also the industrial metaverse and
yesterday
um Siemens and Nvidia announced really a
partnership and we try to reach for
something bigger are nothing smaller
than really trying to transform the
manufacturing industry and really
bringing together these high-end physics
models as as we provide them Siemens
um together with really these
Interactive
um virtual walls and AI Technologies
but but enough of advertisements so what
is digital twins
um typically you know I I start with a
rather lengthy introduction trying to
provide the details but actually our
communication Department did quite a
great job and they have a very very nice
explainer on digital Twins and I rather
would you know refer you afterwards
going to to the YouTube
channel of Siemens I've just follow the
links or the QR code and and watch that
that three minutes uh introductionary
video
um so for the moment you know I I would
just
describe it as I would like to have
digital replicas
accepted as full substitutes for the
reality which we can use
to do decision making so always having
in mind actually a purpose would like to
predict how a system behaves and then
out of this predictions you know two
decisions for for real world assets
um why am I excited or why is now you
know the time to speak about the
development digital models and all this
it's not a news story it's it's rather
old the main reason is is it's really
the technology uh which has evolved so
much so that this now becomes really
possible on Industrial scale
um if you look at the data the compute
power the connectivity which is the
basic ingredient for the digital twins I
mean that that's all there these days
probably even have too much data we have
the complete infrastructures there's a
cloud HPC clusters
user experience you know fast networks
to to really run these computations
um also the algorithms themselves
whether it's AI machine learning or
physics algorithms
um are on a level really that that we
can go the next steps bring that into
applications and on the other hand
there's lots of applications really
requiring digital twins
um in order to be successful and then a
famous example or my favorite example is
always 3D printing all of a sudden you
have these super complex shapes you can
produced but the challenge is how do you
design them so um that that's you know
digital digital are the applications
basically need the digital twins to go
the next steps and here really hard of
all that it's computing power AI machine
learning and mass physics based models
and that's what what I'll be talking
um the next 30 to 40 minutes about
um also put your some some examples but
but I'll jump over that and rather look
a little bit or speak a little bit about
you know why do we need machine learning
Nick at all and to many people I I speak
in particular there is from the
computational science and engineering
it's all about well you know digital
twins isn't that just modeling and
simulation Technologies we have you know
since since ages
um why why is it relevant
um to at all look into novel
Technologies
and the key thing is we might have all
these nice Technologies but is really
Bound by our expert resources the
efforts these expert needs and it's not
really the technology so that just the
time for many of these you know
applications to get to an appropriate
model to get to to a fast enough model
to connect all those different software
Landscapes that's really a key blocking
Factor what we could see here is is a
survey I did a couple of well months or
probably a year ago on LinkedIn really
trying to figure out or highlighting
what are the bottlenecks as really not
the compute power whatever it's really
this effort of experts to build models
and and connect the different uh
software landscape
and that is really what we need from
industrial point of view new tools so
that we can do that at scale and are not
any more expert bound
and here
I really really believe that bringing
together the machine learning on the one
hand side so leveraging the data the
observations we have these days
abundantly as well as our simulation
models Infuse them to really come
towards digital twins
um for the talk today I'll Focus
um more or to large extents really on
the simulation models and how we could
use machine learning to accelerate
the predictions to get closer to real
time and less about informing simulation
models from data
um to do that I'd like to to to take as
a guiding principle kind of
um well what I would call here a
mathematical architecture of predictive
models so so how does the classical
model based approach with the numerical
solver in in the background look like
well we have a model that you know the
model goes into a solver solver it does
a prediction next time step goes back to
the model and you have the circle of you
know the equations and the mathematical
solver and the background doing the
prediction
um then of course the model that's why I
put your system model typically have you
know different sub models and if it's a
3D multi-physics or 3D physics problem
like computational fluid dynamics
discretization also comes comes into
play
and then you have lots of different
input data that's on the one hand side
you know boundary conditions but on the
other hand which is also quite important
really you know numerical parameter time
step sizes uh Etc at last but at least
very often that is
build really into an optimization Loop
um to support that decision making and
optimization I would also see here in
the general case really model predictive
controllers
and now if looking at that there's many
many different you know opportunities
use cases where we could use really
machine learning to accelerate these the
different steps to to to make the
different steps less expert bounds to
get to the right models to get to the
right settings Etc
um and it really all starts at simple
use cases like like the input data yeah
finding the right numerical parameters
you need to set for your simulation I
mean that depends typically on
experience and what what is the right
the optimal Times tab size to put into
the right mesh size Etc how long will
the simulation run will it converge at
all with these parameters that's
something where we could use machine
learning to support
well the expert or the non-expert trying
to run that simulation
um
on the discretization site uh when we do
you know discretization of Continuum
equations for for multiphysics
computations machine learning can use
can be used to to support you the
engineer to do that automatically to
come up with optimal grids
um speaking about the models yeah we
very often have or might have quite
quite accurate models we also understand
the models but then to get an
abstraction or you know a higher scale
model which we could put into a system
context which is fast enough is missing
again here machine learning can help to
derive those models if you like to have
fast well
responsive models
um response surface models
um packaging basically did the whole
solver and just you know take the input
parameters predict the prediction again
machine learning can help
um even going down into the single
solver steps we can use machine learning
to accelerate that solver
um just to get faster to the same result
last but least another use case are when
we go to the optimization say case or
challenge is is you know can we do those
things explainable
um to understand really what what
machine learning is does
um
what I like to do today and other thesis
there's always quite quite a number of
questions um I think I'll get back to
them later in the talk or rather at the
end
um
pick out here three use cases
um what were you know I together with
the people I mentioned up front worked
on and try to you know deep dive a
little bit highlighted what is
opportunities and challenges and also
trying to to give a feedback or from my
point of view what is working and what
are more successful approaches and what
are not not that successful approaches
and also taking here a little bit
um
personal historical perspectives also
really taking you a little bit with with
my journey into this machine learning
field
um says it really all started a couple
of years ago when I looked into Optimum
mesh refinement and how can can machine
learning help there
so um put the goal quite quite simple
like to have you know first prediction
of of designs in Virtual wind tunnels so
cfd simulation that case a 2d cfd
simulation we just put an object in the
Wind Tunnel I would like to get that
prediction as fast as possible with an
optimal accuracy and then of course the
question is what what is a good Mash how
do you distribute optimal living degrees
of freedom
and now you might answer well that's
that problem is solved there is
something like goal oriented error
estimators uh you can use to drive your
adaptive mesh refinement and yes that is
true but the big challenge is in order
to go this way uh you really need a
joint solvers which is not available in
all commercial software tools uh you
know you need an expert knowing how to
drive those or set up these solvers so
in a way that that's limited and the
question was can you learn that with
machine learning and what we did here
really is we took the very very big data
approach to get there and then to look
into that
um
so we started uh with uh well it's all
2D one inflow condition but different
geometries and we did quite a number of
simulation
simulations are better with calculations
of optimal meshes using well dual
weighted error estimators so goal
oriented in that case I think the goal
was uh predict the lift as accurate as
possible
and the number of simulations here on
the on the supermarket given then those
those Optimum measures we put on top
well I'm put on top um image processing
says in the end the idea was can we use
you know neural networks combinational
neural networks from the image Community
um to kind of predict at least not the
mesh structures but optimal meshed
entities and then feed that into a
measure
and in order to do that we used here a
commercial tool you know also here the
the students spend lots of time
developing optimal scheduling algorithms
so that we really could could exploit
um that the supercomputer here the
supermarket
um and then in the end I said that you
know using standard Technologies can be
convolutionary networks are we then
tried you know given a new unknown
geometry and optimal
mesh density distribution you could then
put into a measure
um and why I said big data approach and
why you know we all have these optimal
schedulings the super mooc Etc is
because we really did hear 60 000 2D
wind tunnel simulations using a
commercial cfd code because we wanted to
see you know how far far can we go
um as that the idea is you have geometry
um and for this geometry you would like
to predict
an optimal mesh density feed that mesh
density then into a measure let me see
what I got here
um beat that then into to a measure and
solve it then then buy a commercial code
and the idea is that that you know
replacing the first two steps by a
machine learning solution so that this
can be really used this density as an
input in any kind of simulation tool
even if it does not have a joint
capabilities or you know any type of
goal oriented
um meshing support as said the um neural
network architecture will use pretty
standard here from image analyst
analytics staircase unit architecture
with skip connections and roughly
um 10 Millions
well I actually uh
close to 100 Millions um no
yeah 100 million degrees of freedom
um so that has been kind of the setups
as a rather large Network rather large
data and uh well the good answer is you
know after
sufficient number of training steps 300
epochs uh we get to to quite well uh
accuracy uh on the validation set
um close to uh 99 I thought okay that's
sufficient for us
by the way um because we spoke here
about 60 000 simulations so there's a
large spot once went off of the project
went also into to think how could we
generate appropriate geometry so we
could really use to generate the meshes
and the training because obviously um
you know cannot generate 60 000
geometries manually
um what what does it mean 99 accuracy
that that's something quite quite hard
um to get a gut feeling for so let's
look really at numerical experiments and
what's shown here is two numerical
experiments you see on the left hand
side
um if you would have given the the
geometry to the measure of of the tool
um
the the kind of error estimates
um after you have an optimal mesh and
then the same on the right hand side
they you know working with the mesh
density as predicted here uh by our
neural network
and you see that actually the neural
network does a quite decent job
um in terms of of the quality of the
mesh and the accuracy of the prediction
uh what it does not do do a good job is
really if we go beyond that viewport so
I haven't mentioned yet but we really
focus this mesh density estimation for a
certain part only of the geometry and
well obviously the Wake Etc is they're
not sufficiently refined
um so that's why why all these quality
measures we really focus here on the
viewport
um so so you could say uh quite
quite successful first experiment
um going going this way
um bring together neural networks with
with
um
solvers
uh
you know we we developed a tool where
you can get optimal goal oriented mesh
generation for for any measure
um it has an accuracy of close to 99
and what's very nice with this
technology and that that's why we really
went to as a first use case also for
Mass generation it requires no
validation and if you have a wrong
prediction it does not affect you know
any validation procedure well in the
worst case you just have slow
computation times
well was it a sex story I personally
would say not uh because we really
required 20 000 simulations to get to
that accuracy for a single wind tunnel
configuration and only 2D you know that
already spent 60 years of compute time
on a superclass there and that that's
nothing feasible if you would like
to go to 3D multiple inflow speeds Etc
and
but the the key learning and why I'm
also sharing this is this example and I
think it's it's very important to make
also people aware is that these brute
forces or Big Data approaches will
likely not work for many engineering
applications also when I you know often
talk to to Engineers they see you know
the Dal e example for example what you
could do there was generative things the
alpha fold the alpha code Etc alphago is
another example but that is really data
sizes uh which are very very hard to
generate on an engineering level
so that's why I'm trying to Advocate
whatever we do here uh you know we we
should put in more intelligence and
really try to fuse much much better
um the simulation
or modeling Technologies as well as the
machine learning not taking this you
know generate less of data and run in
your network on it
um so that's why my my next focus is is
on the model identification
um so instead of you know trying
to learn the relationship between input
data and the prediction let's focus on a
single part of the model and not not
even the identification of the complete
System model but just of a subset of of
that System model because that is
actually something
um you know what we might generate data
it's the model is well known quite quite
confined we might even you know generate
data from from small scale simulation
and try to learn that and that would be
already an enormous value uh the use
case
um we we worked on here is uh coming
from the chemical industry and that is
cooling of a multitubular reactor
um so the reactor is consisting of lots
of tubes and those tubes a reaction is
taking place and you would like to
control the temperature in those tubes
and in order to do that you have a
coolant um
flowing around those tubes and changing
the flow rates Etc you can then
indirectly control uh the the
temperature distributions in those tubes
but of course if you'd like to do that
um with all the uncertainties around Etc
um you really need real-time prediction
of of those complex uh cooling flows and
that in the end goes really to what
what's well known as model order
reduction
um with the ambition to to reuse these
reduce order models in in a larger
setting
um so so that's why I've you know would
say that that's kind of combination of
model identification and model order
reduction because we identify the model
based on high fidelity simulations
I think the the process is very well
known so I'll jump jump over that you
had Benjamin Pierce though for also here
speaking about what he's doing so you
know generate lots of snapshots also you
know many of you are working on that
identify
um you know the the low dimensional
manifold you'd like to train your
reduced order model onto
by then the the time stepping operators
and uh well the end is is the reduced
order model and there's lots of
different ways you know looking into
that
um ourselves did quite a lot of the
neural networks but I'd like to get back
to to the operator inference because I
think um that's a very very nice
approach and also highlighting you know
the strings if you do not use neural
networks but try to go back to simple
linear or quadratic relationships uh
because I I strongly believe that that
you know as long as we're not in high
Dimensions when really the power of
neural networks kicks in in low
dimensionals you know polynomials it
should be probably tried always first
um and and in particular on the
engineering slides you know so many of
our models are based on Taylor series so
whenever we learn something we we should
go maybe without polynomial spirit
um well also it's a glass box box
approach so we have kind kind of some
some insight but then you know trying
those things out
well there's quite some challenges you
need quite good exact estimates of the
time derivatives and there's some magic
stabilization parameters in there so the
crash we posed here you know can can we
do that better again taking some
technologies from from you know explored
in other fields of machine learning and
bringing that into the concept of
operator inference
um in order to explain a little bit what
we did let me quickly uh review the
classical operator interference so the
classical operator inference basically
what it does you look at you know well
first of all you reduce
most cases of pod uh principle component
analysis to project your high
dimensional data in your low dimensional
data you try in this low dimensional
data estimates the time derivatives on
the one hand side and then you try to
identify a model predicting those time
uh derivatives and minimize uh the
difference between them so that means in
each of the time steps you basically try
to get what the time derivative predicts
and what the
um what the model predicts uh to to get
that as minimal as possible and then on
top you need some some regularization
um
and that's really step here focusing on
on the individual time steps and I think
that that's really the key thing so we
try at each time step to minimize the
diff difference and not to look at the
whole trajectory
um that really requires us because we
look at each time step having these good
time
[Music]
um
estimates of the time derivatives the
stabilization very often challenging to
tune and last but not least
um the regression doesn't work well in
many cases and is not really optimal
um so so because we like very much the
concept of this polynomial approach of
this explicit approach we we you know we
our ambition was to to look for for
different
opportunities Technologies how to do
that and
um
was at that time when when you know the
neuro ode paper got quite some attention
um later you know being described as
differentiable machine learning
differentiable solvers so that is kind
of the spirit wanted to put into here
um so the key idea is instead of you
know taking each individual time step
Trying to minimize the residual there
between the observed time derivative and
the time derivative predicted by the
model we say okay in the end we are not
interested in time derivative but we are
interested in trajectories so let us
minimize the trajectories under the
constraint of course that one trajectory
is the observed one and the other
trajectory is predicted by the model
um that's actually classical
um
constrained optimization
um is that minimizing that and then
there is lots of different Technologies
in order to do that
um you can either say okay that requires
to solve an additional however you call
that from from which Community you are
you will join problem the kkt system or
from a machine learning perspective you
know just write the solver and in the
loss function and differentiate who
solve it through an auto differentiation
approach to using a Jax framework or
something or Julia or something similar
and what we actually did here is because
the system is so simple we resolve the
KK or set up the kkt system ourselves
and really solve the forward and the
backward problem to do the training
and what can be seen very nicely here is
here's a comparison of that operator
inference on the left hand side we'll
use the classical ones you know
minimizing the residuals on each time
step and on the right hand side really
minimizing the complete trajectories
there's still this peak in in the middle
but the peak is because the training
data we we looked at or the set of of
applications we looked and that was
always at the middle of the time a
switch in the heating behavior and so
that's why which is not appropriately
captured the Dynamics there so that's
why there is still this local error Peak
what we can nicely see is that really
using this differential approach
um you know not only don't we need any
magic stabilization parameters Etc but
we get also a much older nicer
regression of the problem and all these
issues you know also with getting the
right time estimators of time derivative
is not there and it's a much much more
stable approach from industrial point
point of view
um
so again I I would say you know Spirit
of these neural old neural Odes or um
you know differentiable solvers
combined with the idea to use the same
optimization technique techniques on
polynomials
um you might also argue well that's
basically a kind of optimal control
where you try to tune your parameters of
the polynomials
um so so that you meet the observed
trajectory
could could be another point of view
because in the end all this is is just
basic very classical constraint
optimization and so so the nice result
here is uh the the the two predictions
here for for the one of the validation
cases are basically indistinguishable
um on the top it is the 3D physics uh
with a commercial cfd solver and 400 000
degrees of freedom and at the bottom
it's really an explicit and that's a
very nice thing
ode was eight degrees of freedom Mass so
you can really write it down
uh and this you know writing that down
explicitly is also very important having
in mind would like to reuse that in a
different tool not all tools I mean it's
slowly changing support that you can you
know hand over in your network uh to be
integrated there if you speak about
control applications would like to
implement something like this you know
directly on a controller then also
neural networks is really an option so
that's why here
um you know this the small polynomial
approach is is really a very nice way to
do it
um
I think the key benefit is really could
accelerate here by orders of magnitude
uh the speed we have that explicit form
and
um what I would like to highlight this
differential will solve a technology
this is a really tightly differentiating
or integrating the solver in the
optimization approach is something we
want one should basically consider in
any
um
machine learning approach if possible
a drawback is it requires of course some
solver in intrusiveness
um and you know if the solver does not
really provide joint capabilities then
then it's challenging
um to to drive these these approaches
um of course you can always you know
rewrite a solver but from from
industrial perspective you of course
would like to do that in a solver uh
you'll be also using at the end
um and the main learning case or point I
wanted to make here is uh
not always go straightly with with the
high dimensional approximators but but
also sometimes considered to have simple
function approximators
um because in the end Taylor expunctions
which we you know daily use in
engineering is in the end polynomials
um I would like to close a little bit um
that the presentation was with a very
very early topic
um
we're working in into looking into and
that that's really you know the ambition
can can we accelerate solvers by means
of machine learning
um well the goal is obvious would like
to have fast computational prediction of
unknown flows so we would like to use
that to do prediction without extensive
training data generation
um so the challenge is really to do that
agnostic to specific geometries or
specific models
and also would like to do another that's
an issue I have very often you know
looking at a similar approaches
um we don't really want to reinvent
solve a technology we want to improve
the most efficient solvers available and
also Benchmark ourselves with the most
efficiency of these solvers available
um doing that well the most efficient
solver technology we have for cfd these
days is geometric multi-grid solvers
um for those of you who are not aware of
that the Gauss algorithm is is if your
Matrix is n times n so n and numbers of
unknown is n to the power of three in
complexity iterative sparse solvers is n
to the power of two geometric multi
solvers is really linear in the amount
of unknowns so that's why why you know
this is really optimal solver technology
and the key idea what this relies on and
that's actually quite quite important to
understand
um The Next Step so that's why I'm doing
this this small small um you know deep
dive here is
what I show here is the result of a very
simple 2D uh 2D diffusion equation it is
random initial parameters or a random
initialization using an iterative solver
and so after you know having not done a
an iteration the error is quite randomly
distributed but then if you do three
iterations with a symbol iterative
Jacobi solver you smooth out those high
frequency errors so so it
you still have low frequency errors but
you've smoothed out the high frequency
errors and that that's the basic concept
uh one uses in in the geometric
multi-grade solver so the key idea is
you smooth out on a fine grits
The High Frequency errors and then
project the solution to a much coarser
grid and then what was you know low
frequency errors on the the fine grid
turns out to be high frequency errors on
the causal grid and then you repeat that
procedure all the way down if you're to
a level which you can solve it with a
direct solver and then you go back and
that's here called The V cycle so
there's many many other Cycles how you
can do that but that's the basic idea
um
now now our approach here was okay let's
assume we have that that multi-grade
solver it's it's already efficient what
we actually would like to do in a spirit
of a Multiverse or super resolution
scheme can we use that or can we use
neural networks to go one level finer
and do a predictions on on a much finer
level and then also not only to have the
flow visualized on on that level but
also take that newly generated
information back into to the solution
scheme because obviously that's then
very much influences the the further
evolution of the flow
so that's that's kind kind of of the
approach we we've taken here
um you know using a neural network to go
one level or multiple levels deeper more
accurate and in a super resolution
fashion
and the key Advantage here of um the uh
geometric multi solvers is that the
smoothing is is a local schema so we
interact only
are all the operators interact only
locally
and that that means that that would like
to train this this solution here
um so we solve up to a level L use the
Deep neural network to correct that
solution and then you know
take that information from the
correction back to the level L do the
next solve step
Etc but if you like to train that
um we train really on each patch so we
really train on each patch of of of the
uh computational grid which means a
simulation is not only a single data set
but a simulation consists obviously of
you know many different of these patches
so that all of a sudden a simulation is
not one data point but depending on the
size of the simulation of thousands ten
thousands of of data points and that
really solves this issue of how to
generate appropriate data
um and that is is really a key here
um and a very much different to to the
first approach that I've shown all of a
sudden this data generation gets simple
and the hope is also because it only
looks at local properties
um extrapolation will be much much
better
um than training the whole thing
uh what you can see here is is a first
results
um
of of you know the standard single
cylinder in in a flow uh problem I'm at
the very top uh on the right hand side
is the simulation with um L plus one
level or actually I think L was here
four or five I'm not really remembering
correctly
um at the bottom is the prediction on a
causal level so that means l
and in the middle is the the correction
of the L are using the neural network
and one can clearly see here that using
the neural network we are much much more
accurate
um than just staying on the level hole
um of course the next question is what
price do we need to to pay and that's
shown here
um so the top is is the fine multi-grid
at one line beneath is is the multi-grid
with a level L and here you can see
nicely the linear complexity also in
times of the computation roughly
and then we have a
that plus the correction uh using the
neural network
um well we only get the factor of two
here but but we only go one level up and
and you know our expectation is that
that we would like to try to push this
further to the extreme so at least to
get a order of magnitude so really go a
couple of levels up uh in in the next
steps
um also I've been looking at pictures is
one thing you can also then compare that
with uh the drag and the lift and what
you nicely see here
um if you go up one level or even two
level this approach um you accurately or
more accurately cover the drag as well
as the lift
and so far what I've shown you here is
all trained for the signal cylinder
problem I made the Bold statement or the
Bold claim well how well does this
generalize and so we took exactly that
that data we generated up front and took
that to to different applications
uh um first
you know flows without a cylinder
um so that's the flow around around a
corner in the channel
um and a simple Channel flow you can see
that on the simplest Channel flow we
don't do that well yeah we're a little
bit off we lose the Symmetry
um here here at the bottom part
um but on the left hand side I mean
actually still quite good having in mind
you know we haven't trained it on on
that data it doesn't really destroy
anything
but then if we go one one step below
um you know we even can can do things
and that's probably interesting when we
look at the drag at the lift rather on
the left hand side on the figures
improve predictions for the case with
two cylinders and that's something you
know not even
well not even close it's probably wrong
but but the training hasn't seen only
the one cylinder flow and not not the
two cylinder flow and having this this
um you know local
um training and you know the global
information is still capped and
calculated to the solver uh we we can
see it nice or nicely well it
generalizes better I don't think it's
still still some work to be done here
um but but we are quite quite surprised
how well the system did uh you know not
having trained it there
foreign
solver uh acceleration I think this is
local patchwise approach the super
resolution really trying to deeply
integrate the solver as well as the
machine learning is a way to overcome
this data issue and the thing is also
similar to the spirit really um of the
example four for the model order
reduction really try to embrace the
solver in in the training or in the
machine learning model is is key
um
then this local structure
this local training of course makes
makes generalization much much
easier yeah because these local features
you have many of those in in the flow
and and last but not least here we
worked only on the solvers so so that
you know allows to build or extend
classically well proven solver
technology
um and even if that is is you know only
as initial guesses maybe uh for for an
iterative solver and accelerate there so
so that you know the last step you can
still go with your well validated and
certified solver technology
um so far that that's you know only
First Steps only a Mild improvement only
one or two level up
um what we haven't done here completely
so so far it's all residual based
um not really differentiated to this
through the solver I think there there's
you know lots of opportunities
um for for future research
um main message from my point here is
really I think deeply integrating
machine learning and solver technology
is is the future
and um well there's many many more
interesting use cases happy to to
provide to you know
some pointers to to work we've done
there in the past
um just just let me know and let me
quickly break up before we come come to
questions I I really think you know not
only what we do at Siemens but in
general
uh whether it's the iot The Internet of
Things whether it's the metaverse it's
really a you know a new age a very uh
break great time being being a
computational scientist because all
these technologies will require much
much more
um novel Predictive Technologies and the
the solvers will have completely
different requirements than to do
solvers we've seen before
um you know they will be used
autonomously by by non-experts they will
be you know looked at having much much
faster response times they they should
calibrate automatically to data if used
during paralyzed a parallel to the
operations
um it's a complete different
requirements and that in the end and uh
you know leads really to to lots of
different
um
research questions
um and not only on the computational
side so that that's something which
which is quite quite important for me
personally because I think also on you
know looking at the user how can we you
know guide the user provide different
experience
um is is really a key thing here uh what
research could
could support and drive novel industrial
applications
um and then hopefully and with this I'd
like like to close you know get really
to to to these impressive results also
industrial applications what we see um
on the pure machine learning side on on
the generative algorithms for for art
Etc and and here the picture I just took
I could not resist playing around with a
Dali 2
um and it's quite quite quite impressive
yes you just give it text and it comes
up with these nice
um paintings or whatever photographs
visualizations and that's kind of uh
what I would love to see you know uh
the combination of machine learning and
and uh simulations in in the future but
at the same time I think it's still a
long way to get to that level
good
all right thank you so much for the
wonderful talk dark um I enjoyed it a
lot okay let's get into the uh q a
session we do have a
many questions
um in the chat room uh let's start from
let's Trace back what is the first one
uh the first one is from Pat
in your definition most digital twins be
induced from data or can they instead be
created manually by humans or is
induction simply a more effective
approach to build them
well first of all I try to be away from
definitions of digital Twins and and
rather it's you know take take a
philosophical approach so I really would
like to have in the end is is a reliable
sufficiently accurate digital
counterpart of of the real world asset
um and whatever technology helps us
to to get to that effectively is is is
is is the right technology
um
obviously you know today it's mostly
created manually by by humans
um but that is also the the key
limitation of of that technology because
we we simply don't have enough experts
and so that's why I think you know in
being induced from data reusing
knowledge like we've seen from the from
the uh reduced order models
um has has a big big opportunity uh but
but I would not say you know must the
the one or the other uh it's all about
which which serves the the application
we have in mind in the end
all right sounds good
um
okay the next question is from Rob Hayes
um he asked what I cannot see from this
explanation is why on analytic a model
with some stochastic uncertainty folded
in will not be as good as
or better than the digital twins can you
clarify
um I think what he was pointing at
specific slides in the beginning well
maybe I can can quickly comment on on
that so first of all you know specific
analytical model with stochastic
uncertainty in it um is a great digital
twin
um the key challenge will be how to get
to to that analytical model
which is sufficiently accurate and
insufficiently fast if we do have that
model yeah well then by all means use
use that model
um if you don't have it and very often
you know the energy conservation Mass
conservation momentum conservation all
that that's well known but very often we
struggle
with closure models
uh well very often we we struggle to to
uplift the model
um to a more macroscopic scale where we
where it's fast enough to calculate and
if we don't have the models then here
that's really what I think the machine
learning combination with the data
models can can help but as you know if
we have an analytical model with
stochastic uncertainty
um or even results
stochastics and the quantification in
there you know then we should definitely
go with that analytical model
I mean the the way analytical model is
derived is um is from data in some
awesome to some extent okay so so sorry
I I thought that well then also if if
you do have you know the data model and
that that works yes then you should go
with the data model
but then you know for data models you
need more and more data but if you have
that that data then you should do that
if you don't have it try to enrich it
with physics knowledge
so same same arguments holds there
yeah okay um the next question is I
don't know if this is a question right
now but by uh OCTA octavi
um he he commented that usually don't
analytical models have many assumptions
of the System Incorporated
yeah yes yes of course
and that that is is I guess also very
much the strings yeah because you could
see on the cfd side we haven't trained
it for for some of the situations
um
but but because it has you know all this
this knowledge integrated it at least
didn't do harm yeah we we we we didn't
get get worse predictions
um
then then the solve on on the level
all right let's move on to the next
question next question is by Pat again
um does it have to be a neural network
or it would induce
government equation and parameters
stated in traditional form he's already
answered that I think I mean I I asked
that when it sounded like he was gonna
be one of those neural network Fanatics
and I think he's
clearly much broader than that so thank
you
all right sounds good uh maybe next
question is also answered like why would
you use your arbitrary polynomials
rather than a defining space of a
physically plausible equations based on
domain knowledge
um if first of all I like that neural
network frenetic
instructions
um
well I guess guess again the answer here
is is the same if if we do have if we do
have the expert available with the
domain knowledge then then you should
always go go with that and really all
this I would only advocate for if you
don't have that domain knowledge
all right sounds good okay next question
is by John
he has two questions can a digital twin
also learn the model from sensor data
during a training period of time rather
than from solving tdes instead of
um so generally speaking can you talk
more about the connection between sensor
data and the digital twins
um
yeah I mean in the ideal case of course
um you know we we should use as much
sensor data as as possible
um however you know many of the
applications I have worked in in the
past and looked at
um
there is not that much sensor data
available and because typically as as
discussed you know doing a digital twin
doing doing those analytical models is
is rather costly so um we we typically
go first for for applications to look at
where you don't have abundantly data you
could could immediately train train a
neural network or any other machine
learning
um process but rather try to go for the
cases where there is sparse data and
still try to combine that then
to to do some predictions
um so so obviously when we use sensor
data in those applications and another
example I've shown not shown here
because I think I talked too often about
that is at least uh checking for Plus
for calibration of of the model we do
have
um as well as for checking plausibility
um estimating error so that's typically
uh where we use the sensor data but not
really for training or learning a model
okay okay uh next question maybe you
just make this point that the reason is
simply
um if there is abundantly data Etc then
you probably would not need all this you
know more sophisticated effort to do
things in a simple
machine learning based model would do
the job like a gaussian process
okay uh the next question from Pat again
your examples have focused on pde models
that have a strong spatial aspect but I
have seen other work on digital twins
that focused on complex but non-spatial
models some with Odes
and some closer to discrete event models
do you count those as digital twins as
well
yes of course I would con count those as
digital twins as as well the main reason
I have pre you know a strong Focus here
and whatever presented on 3D physics is
uh first of all because
I have a
you know 3D background that's what I did
most most of my life and the second nice
argument also is I mean three data
always have strong correlations and that
makes of course things like model or
reduction much easier than if you go
with uh you know more complex systems
okay so the pad also um you know nicely
at least it's some relevant uh the work
on the chat so everyone is welcome to
check that and the next question is by
thailings what do you think are the most
difficult or technical challenges you
encountered in in applying deep learning
for learning solo game models
I guess your personal experience well my
my personal experience is um
I have sulfur not really used deep
learning really
um and and the main reason is deep
learning I mean except the first example
I've shown about about the grid
refinement which which is of course deep
learning is that deep learning means you
know lots of neurons lots of degrees of
freedom
means lots of data and and for most of
these applications we we simply have not
the data or cannot afford to generate
that that data so that's why by also you
know trying to put a focus on if
possible use polynomials well sometimes
it might make sense to to you know go go
with neural networks because if they
give you a much much bigger freedom in
terms of the functional space in the
background
um then of course neural networks but
but it's always rather shallow ones than
the super big deep learning models
okay
uh next question from Pat again complex
models that involve long casual change
will propagate uncertainty so that final
predictions have wide error bounds do
you know of any causal chains
uh
goggle things okay do you know of any
general response to this challenge this
will arise Less in pde models of spatial
systems that in
ode
models of non-spatial ones
well uh hard hard to to answer here
because I don't have too much experience
and but but I guess this is is the
reason why I favor also so much
um these approaches where you have you
know the differentiable solver or or you
know neural Odes uh however you call it
constraint optimization because it
really looks at the trajectory and the
trajectory includes the information how
errors are propagated now whereas if you
just look at individual residuals you're
losing that that information
yeah let me let me clarify the question
um and it's imagine that you have data
on components of a complex system and
you uh and you uh you use induction to
build models of those components
but you don't have data on the overall
system and now you want to put them
together uh to make predictions about
about what's going to happen in the
overall system
um there's going to be the individual
models will be will be have errors and
those errors will get propagated and
that's going to be a big issue because
if the errors are enough if their
propagation is large enough then the
bounds on on the predictions are going
to be useless now I know that
the in the neural net Community there's
this idea of of maybe you can train
components but then you train the entire
system Right End to End you could do
that if you have the data but often you
you may not you may only have data on
the component systems and so I I believe
this is a big challenge I didn't think
that you had an answer because I don't
know that there is an answer I just
think that it's a it's a point worth
raising in the context of the goal of
building robust accurate digital twins
yeah I I completely agree and then as I
said my My Hope and because is really to
think a little bit into this directions
of of those differentiable solvers so
trying to to take in a way into account
how that would be solved in in a bigger
solver
thank you all right
um next question is by George
um how do you manage to deploy your
machine learning models out of the
Siemens commercial softwares for example
star CCM what procedure do you mainly
follow for instance solve the simulation
extract the results and prepare machine
learning models what's your opinion
regarding physics informed neural
network have so-called pins and the ROMs
to combine them with your already
developed methodologies
um so on the star CM plus site and there
there is uh well
mostly we use it in the results we've
seen the the grit refinement as well as
the multitrary reactor is as we use that
as a data generation engine
um
maybe more and more in terms of a future
perspective but but cannot really talk
talk a detail there they're about things
and then time timelines Etc is of course
I mean star simplus is one of of the few
commercial codes
um which which comes with The Joint
solution capability yeah so so this this
intrusive methods um are basically
supported by by the silver structures
through their joint capabilities so that
I think that there is lots of
opportunities to go also into those
small intrusive mechanisms
um ROMs I think I I spoke a little bit
about uh because the the second case
um is is a reduced order model
um on the pin side
um
if you refer to the very very original
paper of pins I think that there's lots
of of debates around it
um the short answer maybe is
um it they they introduce physics as a
regularizer and that is the way how pins
should be used use pins when you have
data and you need regularization of that
data because you're you're simply have
not enough data I'm using pins as
solvers as as sometimes promoted is
really from my point of view not not the
way to go
um
quick answer is uh first first of all
you train on complete time domains you
lose 3D notion of time
um you have no control over your
function spaces you're not using optimal
solver Technologies so what we have
being a hard time being compared to
state-of-the-art solvers and that's
that's really what I'm missing and I
would also encourage everybody you know
listening to to to to to
to to the presentation today you know
whenever you come up with these machine
learning Technologies please try to
Benchmark them with state-of-the-art
solvers and not just you know with a
standard iterative sparse Matrix solver
or whatever
um or or even a direct solver
um because then it it's really hard you
know if you like to evaluate later on
the capability uh you you renew to do
the evaluations again and
um yeah something I I'd like to push
haven't yet found that time is really
also from the community provide open
data sets where you really say okay this
is state-of-the-art solvers I and solver
technology really try to Benchmark your
results with these high-end computations
um and not with just some random open
source tool not not really meant to be a
high-end Computing tool
okay
um next question is by Raja
could you comment on Extreme or
anomalous event prediction in connection
with your talk
I guess he's well yeah funny science
I I I guess uh
you know much much of the stuff we we do
is really having the anomalous anomalous
event protection in mind
um so so we'd like to do root cause
analysis at least if if the data we
start to observe has nothing to do with
the data before
um then then using this this you know
model based approach we could could at
least trace the the strange Behavior
back to a single component or whatever
and and give at least indications look
this component is starting to show weird
or whatever
um and then you know give feedback to to
the operator of that system you know do
you need to do an emergency shutdown or
can you run that probably and get and
feeling how that that you know where
will evolve how much time you have to to
do what we of course not do and not look
really into is is can can we really do
uh you know quantification of
likelihoods of extreme events when it
comes to validation and certification
because think
to go in in this direction it's still a
very long way for for machine learning
okay
um next question from juanchon
whether it is still twin comes from
stochastic pdes statistical machine
learning or deep learning on observed
data or some combination
alternate how should the digital twins
be updated or recalibrated against its
analog twins
well I think the the most important
thing is it it should be updated uh or
or recalibrated yeah because I mean if
you would like to mimic the real world
and then it should be always up up to
date and the machines are subject to to
wear or whatever that means also you
know if you have a larger system you
update the motor to a different class
and of course you also would need to
update your whole system model how to do
that
um well as said in the end it's a
calibration optimization new learning
task I think the bigger challenge is
really here on on the um
industry
processes you you have
in place yeah your product life cycle
management tools Etc how do you then
officially deploy a new new twin
um if that's running on the edge as part
of the control Etc uh so I think it's
probably a little less the the issue of
of uh really the um calibration learning
uh Technologies
all right sounds good okay the next
question is by uh Dinesh
um he asked does the DNN multi-grid
approach have potential for achieving
real-time predictions like a pure ml
model
um fast enough
it depends on what is is real-time
prediction yeah
um so I think if you really try to aim
for real-time prediction and then let me
take take one of the extreme most
extreme case I've I've worked on is a
prediction of the deformation of a robot
to increase its accuracy and their
real-time means
a prediction every millisecond
um
a guaranteed prediction every
millisecond and that's something yeah
well a machine learning model might
might be able to do but but nothing like
like this
um your network multi-grid approach
um the big strengths of the multi-grid
approach is is acceleration on the one
hand side and the other big thing is is
the generalization capability yeah this
will work even if it sees a geometry it
has not seen before yeah I mean you
could just do a Bend IN in your channel
and then remove the the cylinder or put
a second cylinder into it and you still
get reliable predictions
pure ml model would not be able to do
that I think that that's really the the
strengths of of that approach and not
really targeted at real time
sounds good okay next question by Helen
what do you think are the gaps between
some standard pde Benchmark for example
flow through the cylinder or some other
two dpds and practical digital twins
problems for example scalability
more complex or heterogeneous scenario
or any other aspects
um
so I think think
the the standard
Benchmark problems uh what one has
um are are very important because it you
know
it it is a good set of of problems
capturing the relevant aspects of of
most solvers and their capabilities
um so I would not really see the issue
of having
more benchmarks but as that before I
would rather see an issue of you know
not only
describing the Benchmark in terms of
okay nabia stocks and this is geometry
but also in particular for the machine
Learning Community you know provide
things with with pre-computed Solutions
so that they could take the solutions
directly compared with the solutions
um provide timings of of those two
solutions uh provide information how
that scales with increasing the number
of grid points Etc
um so so to really have
relevant quantitative
kpis one could Benchmark or compare the
machine learning Solutions with because
far too often from my point of view that
that's just the Inon Matrix
okay uh thank you dark um I guess we
reached the last question it's by Arc
Hobby
and he wants some more explanation about
your DNN mg method he was
somewhat confused how it works and Etc
well the the key idea is is just on on
your finest level or you know
multiple final fine level you just cut
them out on your multi is
scale um on your multi-grid thing and
you know instead of doing the the
prolongation restriction and smoothing
to to the finer levels respective is
moving on the final levels uh you would
just replace those you know prolongation
restriction steps uh with the machine
learning approach that would not do any
smoothing in between
I see okay thank you so and from your
results uh you show that this is faster
than multi-grid only in the finest level
yeah okay great and and also it is for
me the key point of of the of the talk
which is very interesting like congrats
this is great work uh the key point is
that um
it's it's transferable to UNS completely
unseen fluid cases like the the corner
case you trained with the floor on a
solid body and the same model can can
predict accurate very accurately on
unseen uh case so well I I I I I I would
not say necessarily very accurately yeah
I mean you do not get the nice accuracy
as as for for the case where it has been
trained so so for the moment I would
rather take a more conservative
statement at least it doesn't get worse
yeah whereas if you do a machine
learning you have no control and it
might might bring you a completely
different region and then it starts to
make harm yeah in this case at least
didn't just doesn't make the solution
worse
yeah great and so why why do you think
that happens because you think it's
learning more the local structures so it
can generalize better
I think it's it's really um
so I've spent lots of my previous
research uh and time in in multi-scale
modeling
and also also if you if you look at
flows and our our flow models uh what we
have on the turbulence side it's it's
all multi-scale things and really
finding that the right closure models
etc for those multi-scale effects and
that's in the end all very very local I
think really this local multi-scale
nature is is is the key what what is
exploited and why why this method works
that nicely and the good thing is and
that's why I like to work with with
fluids is is you know that the
turbulence Community has shown there is
something which can be learned
um which generalizes nicely
um so so that's more or less like you
can also say
rediscovering uh by Machine learning
approach what any Engineers working
turbulence anyhow might know
okay great thank you very much great
great work
all right sounds good one additional
question by uh Dinesh are you also
working on multi-scale physics informed
ml that's what I mean
um
yeah I I mean that that's uh basically
um I said the the uh the Sea of dks is a
little bit uh accelerated here you could
already consider as as multi-scale but
but I think multi-scale
um is is an important point point of
view
um what where machine learning can play
really a very very big role and yes
we're working on that you know
identifying the right closure models
when you do multiphysics that could be
turbulence
um that could be porous media flows uh
whatever
sounds good all right I think we you you
hammered all all the questions I mean I
I think this was
the talk with the most questions ever so
far okay I never posted
in the past and we passed like the
um 15 minutes after the designation
sometime thank you so much Dirk for the
wonderful talk and then a wonderful q a
sessions I mean and especially given the
situation that you are in Europe and
late evening right now for you and
spending the time with us and that was
great especially for you
also thank you very much from my side
for for organizing this yes I benefited
a lot from this and so the least I could
do is is to give something back with
with a talk it's very serious awesome
awesome Mutual Mutual beneficial yeah
all right sounds good thank you so much
okay that concludes the talk today uh
let me stop the